die entwicklung ist so dass hinter mir
gerade aktuellen polizeieinsatz nochmal
an läuft am tatort hier selbst hier
können das einmal zeigen die
polizeitaucher aus bochum sind hier im
einsatz und wir zeigen dass mal der
taucher ist da vorne im wasser und
suchten nach möglichen weiteren
beweismitteln wir befinden uns hier
direkt nahe des tatortes und bei diesem
tatort fehlt möglicherweise noch ein
wichtiges beweismittel und zwar haben
wir erfahren dass die frau
möglicherweise eben erstochen wurde und
dann könnte es sein dass die polizei
genau nach diesem tatmesser jetzt hier
sucht und finden will was der täter
möglicherweise nach der tat
weggeschmissen hat es fehlen auch
kleidungsstücke der frau sie wurde halb
nackt gefunden und vor diesem
hintergrund kann man davon ausgehen dass
die polizei genau nach diesen
beweismittel in diesem tempel jetzt hier
sucht wir befinden uns in der nähe vom
oberlandesgericht also ist mitten in der
innenstadt form haben ein kleiner park
der ist nicht besonders abgelegen ist
bewohnt sind verkehrs
hauptverkehrsstraßen drumherum und
trotzdem ist es so gewesen dass die frau
in der nacht zu sonntag eben hier auf
ihren täter getroffen ist in westfalen
für diejenigen die sich deutlicher
auskennt ist das ungefähr in der nähe
von dortmund zwischen dortmund und
münster so in etwa wien nimmt die
bevölkerung in haben diese tat auf
die bevölkerung ist schockiert natürlich
über diese tat die frauen sind total
verunsichert man muss sich vorstellen
eine frau fährt abends nach der disco
nach einem club besuch einfach nach
hause mit dem fahrrad viele fahren hier
mit dem fahrrad das ist hier sehr
flachen hand und dann plötzlich trifft
sie auf einen täter wird möglicherweise
missbraucht und ermordet wir können das
einmal hier zeigen hier sind teddybären
hier sind kerzen hier liegen auch ein
paar blumen und das ist wirklich gesagt
wirklich nur drei meter ungefähr neben
dem tatort und hier ist diese
schreckliche tat passiert und
möglicherweise hat die frau hier im park
einer gehört wenn sie noch um hilfe
gerufen hat was auch noch wichtig ist
sind neue details die wir jetzt exklusiv
erfahren haben und zwar soll die polizei
bereits am gestrigen abend einen
27-jährigen tatverdächtigen festgenommen
haben die ermittler sind sich wohl
sicher dass es sich um den täter handelt
ob er jetzt wirklich heute dem
haftrichter vorgeführt in
untersuchungshaft gebracht wird klärt
sich gerade in diesen minuten die
polizei geht von einem sexualdelikt aus
und geht davon aus dass der täter es
bereits ebenso auf die frau eingestochen
hat ob vor der tat ob nach dieser sexual
tat das ist noch nicht klar dass klären
gerade weitere untersuchungen jedenfalls
glauben die ermittler sie haben den
täter und das wäre natürlich für die
menschen hier in hamm so schrecklich die
tat ist die wichtigste botschaft erst
mal weil das sagt mir eben auch hier
spaziergänger schon gestern abend waren
die straßen wie leergefegt keine frau
war auf der straße zu sehen und es
herrscht halt einfach ganz große angst
läuft hier ein täter herum der es auf
frauen abgesehen hat frank das wäre
natürlich wirklich beruhigend wenn es
tatsächlich der täter wäre hast du denn
was gehört dazu ob die beiden sich
eventuell schon vorher kannten waren die
vielleicht sogar zusammen feiern die
partymeile ist ja weit entfernt
frank schneider hat er uns im moment
nicht mehr kann frank kannst du uns noch
hören dann gebt uns kurz ein zeichen
sondern soll das jetzt jetzt kann ich
euch wieder hören gerade war der ton
wird genau dann gab der ton weg gezeugt
euch wieder ja die frage danach ob die
beiden sich eventuell kanten in einer
beziehung zueinander standen hattest du
hast du die möglichkeit gehabt da schon
informationen einzuholen
nein das ist ja alles noch sehr frisch
muss sich vorstellen junge frau war hier
abends feiern es ist nach corona man hat
wieder die möglichkeit rauszugehen die
polizei sagt auch sie waren mehreren
lokalitäten war am ende wohl noch an
einem klub sieg trug er noch das
bändchen ein grünes party bändchen so
ein eintrittsbändchen um das handgelenk
und ist dann nach dieser partynacht mit
dem fahrrad die paar meter nach hause
gefahren wollte nach hause fahren und
ist dann hier auf den täter getroffen ob
der täter sie möglicherweise vor schon
in einer der gaststätten der klubs
gesehen hat angesprochen hat sie ihn
vielleicht zurückgewiesen hat er ihr
nach gefahren ist das kann ich nicht
sagen das wissen wir noch nicht das wird
auch gerade ermittelt ich weiß auch
nicht ob der täter sich zu der tat ein
lässt ob er aussagen gemacht hat es kann
natürlich genau so sein dass ja auch auf
dem heimweg war oder hier im park
gewartet hat hier jemand auflauern
wollte das fahrrad der jungen frau wurde
ja wenige meter entfernt gefunden ist
wie zu hause habe sie vom fahrrad
gerissen das klingt eher so darauf dass
er möglicherweise hier ihr aufgelauert
hat und deswegen kann es auch sein das
ist ein reines zufallsopfer war und dass
diese frau einfach zum falschen moment
am falschen ort war die hinter mir kam
das ja noch mal zeigen die taucher sind
jetzt weiter im wasser ist es eine leine
gespannt worden dass man dort sehen kann
an dieser stelle lag die leiche wo die
beamten am rand jetzt stehen unter
dieser trauerweide und da könnte es
natürlich gut sein dass der täter
einfach direkt nach der tatsachen
weggeworfen hat einfach ins wasser
geworfen hat dann weggerannt ist und
diese teile möchte man natürlich finden
weil wenn es wirklich sich um den täter
handelt braucht man natürlich
beweisstücke dass man später ihnen auch
überführen kann und deswegen ist es ganz
wichtig dass die polizei jetzt alles
sicher stellt was sie finden können und
dass eben keine spuren im wasser
vernichtet werden frank haben ist eine
stadt mit sehr vielen sozialen
brennpunkten die gegen den der du stehst
dagegen ist er ein guter schulischer
stadtteil
absolut das ist wie gesagt hier mitten
in der innenstadt ist es gut bürgerlich
es ist ein total idyllischer park assist
auch wunder ist es bizarr eigentlich
dieses wunderschöne wetter heute morgen
seien ein relativ spät sommermorgen kühl
hier im schatten aber die sonne scheint
ist es eigentlich ganz idyllisch hier
sind auch viele spaziergänger und alle
sagen natürlich es ist unglaublich was
hier passiert ist in diesem park und es
ist recht das oberlandesgericht das ist
eine der wichtigsten justizeinrichtungen
nordrhein westfalen ist hier vis á vis
wir können das gerne einmal zeigen das
ist wirklich ein einen steinwurf wie man
immer so sagt entfernt und da ist das
oberlandesgericht und direkt hier vor
ist die junge frau eben auf ihren mörder
getroffen und das beunruhigt die
menschen hier oben geht eine straße
lange fahren autos hier sind menschen
unterwegs nachts natürlich um 34 uhr
wenn die tat vermutlich gewesen ist
nicht aber es ist ein bereich von hand
der überhaupt nicht als kritisch als
gefährlich als beunruhigend haben es
jetzt auch keine stadt wo wo ständig
irgendwie unruhe herrscht wo es in parks
junge gruppen gibt die sich
zusammenrotten wie wir das aus anderen
größeren städten kennen haben es eher
etwas idyllisch an ruhrgebiets land
gelegen richtung ostwestfalen an der a2
da kennt man es vielleicht von der
autobahnabfahrt und wie gesagt die
menschen hier in hamm sind einfach alle
nur völlig erschüttert verunsichert und
hoffen alle dass die polizei den täter
jetzt möglicherweise schon gefasst hat
das hoffen wir alle vielen dank
[Musik]